previously on seven days to die so over
here if you guys come back over here
where I'm at I will not how would I do
that I put a campfire that has all the
necessary
[Laughter]
I don't know I found there's a way both
of us really united against a chef you
know you really did so one of us needs
to grab master chef where's that oh my
god guys look at how sexy I look right
now
[Music]
those boots though when day comes I'm
gonna dig a hole in the ground do I want
to eat rotting flesh or like is that a
no if you're a brave man you would mark
has antibiotics in his chest do i what
an absolute a-hole you also have
bandages in your chest yeah I do and ten
aloe vera Leafs I put yellow bear in
there hey freakin Horton stuff over here
for I had painkillers in there I think
that might be what they're talking about
you have beer you have two beers yeah
man
one for you one for me I guess I'm
focusing on the strength skill trick
that's where I'm going
that's just you this time Bobby I've got
six yoga juice dude yeah nasty
I've got yoga morning I'm gonna go dig a
hole okay you in for clay clay
take a whole day go this is why I can't
deal with Minecraft series because if I
did it would just be 30 episodes would
be digging a hole that's it I just love
to go old dude I'm getting so much
experience for this - holy crap take
that hole bro dude digging is the best
are you gonna make us at least make a
moat around the house somewhat no dude
I'm getting so much clay this is
ridiculous
dude it's good because we definitely
need clay right wait that Forge is
important god Bob yeah yeah it is
important
dad I'm confused at this bit but I guess
I'm along with you no one understands is
digging ivy that kid you know and in
kindergarten is like digging a hole in
the dirt there's just a big hole in the
middle or mr. dig I'm reading books and
like drawing in ship no he would always
bring a shovel as little backpack and
starting digging right in the middle of
[ __ ] floor I was really sorry did
Mark's name used to be mr. dickerson
because I feel like there's any
confusion I might have about his digging
and compulsions mr. dickerson
clearly comes from a long lineage of
diggers and I am NOT at all inclinations
my great-grandmother was of the miner
Sion's
but you know Juliet pigeon edition
pigeon what is yep you got it that's the
one he didn't you got it keep going stop
I don't know why my brain just about
fidgety belén oh there is a skill for
mining I
69er yeah that's what dude those are my
two favorite things cop yeah it's got
the best number in it so like double
Lambo there you know yeah glad you
discovered that I think that's gonna be
good for everyone here good for us the
word you're looking for is us ooh
I hit some rock sir like a pic now
you're really mining there is a pickaxe
oh you need a skill for it damn it
digging to Pluto I don't think people
understand how digging works under
strict don't call me out right I got
this schematic for the first aid bandage
yes that's good do that when you learn
it or is it just one it disappeared
after I used it all right well you're
the guy what ingredients does that name
aloe cream and two cloth fragments oh
yeah I'm fine so the trick is to dig a
hole underneath it and let it all fall
in apparently
whoo hey hey buddy where did you come
from where are you going come on come on
[ __ ]
mm right in the penis I don't know
what's happening over there bub I guess
it doesn't really make sense from your
perspective doesn't come here Oh in your
penis
I swear it's not a dog or Fox this time
it's a person I don't know if you guys
knew this was extremely satisfying I'm
having so much fun yeah this is like
this is like the same reason that people
love Animal Crossing a [ __ ] this is
like a very simple thing but it's very
very satisfied you can dig an animal
crossing not very deep but you can't dig
yeah I'm trying to get this thing to
collapse but it doesn't want to whoa I
might be at the end and entrance to a
dungeon that seems like a thing I'm a
dungeon
[Music]
oh there it goes I did it whoa I did it
oh my god I come to collapse oh it
doesn't give very much stuff though okay
so it's kind of a way see it only gives
sand
oh is this a mini hoard oh [ __ ] I
thought it made Horde yeah there's just
like a small group of like five lead him
into my hole far away from your hole do
you guys want me to dig a moat cuz I can
what I'm digging a moat by the way I'm
just doing that now bunches that sounds
like that sounds good I think that
probably at least a productive way for
me to dig as opposed to a giant hole
have you made that forgit oh yeah that's
what I was - yeah no the forge needs
lots of leather so if you if you see
dogs and stuff out there go kill a bunch
of dogs okay his leather craftable from
anything else other than just getting it
from animal hide i scrapped a leather
like belt to get to or one or whatever
it was yeah whit spikes in the moat
sounds dope actually I've got a monk
with spikes you pray a little yeah I'm
I'm just kind of like building this moat
right around the edge of the spikes I
don't know how effective it'll be but I
think it'll like should I go for it yeah
yeah should have time you look at the
map to see how far along it is you gotta
you got it it looks like about where I
spawned yeah I see it you go for it Bob
I'll keep the mole going the moat is
definitely a necessity so keep keep that
around on it I hope clay has another use
because I am just getting so much clay I
think it does but I honestly don't know
for sure let me also see spike would
spike trap I have no food I'm gonna run
out of stamina out here doing that try
not correct mark trouble what's
happening mark
don't look at me that is correct
oh that is correct
does the air drop Vick on the ground
what am i what am I looking for exactly
yeah it should be like smoking and
everything
well after I crest this Hill I guess
we'll find out that had exploded
cornbread recipe were saved
I'm so far from home guys I don't think
I'm not seeing I'm not seeing the thing
on the ground it was more to your right
I think it was straight due north from
where I was looking I found you people I
love on wit turns into a pirate is the
real winner I think I love all the
stages of Wade son of a biscuit
Bob you haven't tried oh I don't think I
don't think I'm gonna find it
Chad is saying the smoke is already gone
probably damn it oh I found a working
chemistry station I don't even know what
you can do on this I could make glue yay
sounds getting real low gang
oh boy I'm even further away from home
this time than I was last time Bob
divided 47 gases oh you got time you got
time it's 22 right 22 is the bathtub
walk down a mountain 22 is the bad time
I'm apparently hungry I didn't know that
was the thing that could happen
all right the moat is about half done
but all the spikes that are out are set
about half of the building is pretty
well moded up pretty good if I see sue
it can I like boil water and get better
water yes if you have murky water go to
the campfire I was trying to tell you
[ __ ] about because it's got a beaker
it's got a grill in its got the cooking
pot so you should be able to do anything
there I think camp anyway I'm making
water I'm boiling it up so that's pretty
cool man
I can't work can turn the yucca yucca
juice I really wish I didn't spend all
my points on strength I literally spend
every single
drink you big dummy sexual Tyrannosaurus
specialize in unleashing a relentless
assault of blows guaranteed to leave
your prey slack-jawed at your unyielding
stamina sure I kill him with gasoline
and moldy bread good job in boys just
leveled I'm getting myself my mine or 69
yes yeah this shaved one shovel off my
digging here Bob you want a nice suit
thank you actually I have a can of
ravioli and sauce I'm gonna eat that
ravioli in sauce how no no no very good
good stuff our house is almost fully
blocked up yes looking good you've done
good work and Bob's done good work and
I've not done anything today useful good
job man how do I get my stamina back up
that's tied to your food someone cooked
some of the eggs I had in the my stores
I don't know how to cook things but I
totally would do that for you Bob I made
a campfire in the safe room camp oh yeah
yeah yeah there's a campfire in there
I'm gonna make so many boiled eggs guys
oh I should get inside I should get
inside I just need to level up why is
loveling gotten so hard because we're
not killing enough zombies that's where
all the bus today all right I got a
master chef now what can i what can I
cook over here
oh here you can make bacon and eggs let
me drop all the eggs and bacon for the
eggs and meat here all right so I can
make bacon and eggs got it so at what
point does it get real bad day seven
what day is it today
for going into five I can make one bacon
and eggs do we have more meat we've got
to kill more animals I've got animal fat
any more meat on me just because we're
in a bad area we are the deserts not
ideal I don't think cuz it's hard to get
wooden stuff but like we have a town
near is which is nice okay maybe we
should go to the trader maybe they'd
have supplies have you ever been to the
trader yes I have so the nice thing
about the trader is you go to the trader
and then he'll give you quests I'm going
to clear out this area of zombies and
he'll give you tokens and you can use
those casino tokens to buy all kinds of
good [ __ ] we go
because we need to be four to five
before day seven at our house one of us
could go venture out there I guess one
person do it did you guys manage to make
some food and mate I have how hungry you
be I'm at 65 of 103 stamina I'm only at
68 but you can have it in this chest
over here oh wait did you know I have
enough meat to make bacon and eggs
I made one bacon and eggs what we need
to make more it's it was the meat was
the limiting factor it was like two eggs
and a [ __ ] ton of me really I thought
was like a one-to-one okay I don't see
it in here oh there it is bacon and eggs
is five meat two weeks oh honey you can
eat like eight me might as well cook the
eggs in right I don't have any water to
cook like boiled eggs or whatever Hey
oh that's the good stuff guys thank you
alright this time guys you got a you
guys gotta get out there you guys gotta
get some goods alright no lollygagging
in this timer okay alright here's to
four one of you what are the years to
first aid bandages yeah these are the
good kind is this game really still an
alpha yeah some somehow someway I would
it's been a game for like five years
more than that at least 2013 very least
what the hell is going on make the game
dude these guys are breaking in should
we be concerned yes alright are we gonna
do anything about our concern admit well
we will in five minutes I'm not gonna go
down there at night all right yeah you
crazy yes all right
you unbelievable crazy douchebag all
right you piece of garbage right here
I'll be your light source kill him boys
Oh whomp there right there get them the
light is actually quite helpful
you can do it hit him in the face
damn son were definitely here for that
one's done too we can repair this all
right
going down I'll be your light thank you
you are you are my shining light I hear
something
what are you doing good no I you didn't
hit me you didn't hit me you didn't you
can't hit me I almost ran face-first
into the spikes
I like your boat mark I like this design
Thank You Wade apparently it's creative
but I think it's awesome like the moat
good moat hey this there's one in one of
these one of these spike traps you know
what I would have told you if you had
asked don't do that all right
okay don't do that well we've got one
layer spike traps now we just need to
triple that what they didn't even touch
the spike traps I don't know what you're
so afraid of Wade we pretty much have
this under control I think we're fine
dude how bad do you think day 70 is
gonna be not bad this day seven not bad
baby I don't know I also don't know bird
it's better to be prepared than
underprepared also on horde nights on
like day seven there's no hiding like
they just they come for you bro the
zombie virus is just another virus it's
like the flu I like it it I'm gonna be
fine I'm young I'm resilient I ain't
scared I'm going on spring break I'm a
Zoomer that's you that's what you sound
like Zoomers all right mode is calm wait
I gotta I gotta aim the comedy away from
you guys we need to be at peak
efficiency to prepare for the impending
apocalypse
so-called you right zomb owner virus
I made the zubur joke if my viewership
went down by approximately however many
Zoomers we're watching the stream
apparently I'm sorry now they're gone
they're not actually sorry so it's a lie
either way but yes - no flakes or
millennial snowflakes how do you insult
Zoomers I don't even know I don't know
so you don't like dropping by the number
of everyone is welcome at my stream and
shall not be judged I accept all forms
of gonna be markiplier slow to keep up
with mark though any animals that we can
eat I'm just finding zombies to kill I
don't know I'm also I think again the
deserts pride on ideal for oh I'm gonna
die Oh daddy tell them my story yeah I'm
not gonna tell anybody about your story
are you daddy yes all right I got 20
meat I killed a pig and I got some meat
boys ooh nice it really it really did me
in a little bit but I got its meat
alright good tough fight rain down Oh
rain weight doing what can I get us can
i yeah can I jar the rain I don't know
doesn't rain no oh you need snowballs to
make bottled murky water what but
there's rain or whatever it really
should man who does the Scottish accent
at a moment's notice
that's the war
access the man who knows Scottish
accents I know
mark invented Scotsman invented
Scotland's Scotch Scottish people the
word oh I am the Genghis Khan of
Scotland if we're all gonna be honest
here
there's a fox ah do I hunt the Fox or
run ah oh it's killing me it's killing
me apparently it'll come back it's real
atlas it'll come back said that actual
advice or is that just yes yes that's
like the coyote thing yeah I kept coming
back just the way you're saying it makes
it seem like a really unreliable advice
no please rely on me to wade Bob Allen
trusted in me trust in me when you start
singing it just makes me trust you less
oh no the vulture of doom is back get
out of here another note a strange note
I found while looting it's from crazy
Jake clan who's crazy teamed up with the
vulture it's not I told you I told you
the wrong man he'll you said trusted me
he'll you should have trusted in me
what's going on with Wade Oh Frick I
found the coyote he's still pissed he's
dead he had meat in him guys I'm getting
meat out of him I've just seen or
something coyotes meat yes please meat d
meat the coyote I got all the meat out
of him there's probably a better phrase
than D meat I'm going to flash him means
I'm wet
I think I'm getting wet - I'm 18.9%
umbrella guys I'm really getting low oh
it's a snake who invented snakes in this
cave what did you do you should have
looked at encyclopedia that's Christ
look at this thing seriously
oh who did this you should feel terrible
about yourself for the love of God dream
just crying
it's not a snake that's not even a
zombie snake whoever did that you're
terrible guys ruff yeah you're 69 oh
right you're doing that I already got it
yeah you got to make us the pool man we
can't make those high level tools what
tools you can craft higher level higher
quality tools if you take those piranha
did you read tool nipper quality I need
a forged iron which means we need the
Forge which means we need leather
well Bob should have some leather I got
one how much you need I think 10 to make
the forge I've gotten disabled I've got
9 leather on there
listen to me baby I'm listening listen
close I'm listening baby don't listen to
me baby baby I'm 20% umbrella right now
I need some help help
look I just tell you what I got what I'm
working with here I don't know what it
means
uh-huh you tell me would be in 20% of
bro fellers
I'm 21% umbrella and I'm coming in hot I
need some food in me I'm a-comin because
the snake was the terrifying monstrosity
and I'm not gonna let that go for 13,000
years you should have figured out what a
snake is by now I'm just saying I hope
you're a shame to your snakes at some
point it's your responsibility to get on
Wikipedia and figure out what the hell
of snake is I'm not just gonna let you
get away with this it's not a joke just
actually terrifies me that's what
someone thinks the snake is then the
world is not worth saving if I know
anything about snakes it's that the
first adjective I would choose is that
they're slithering and that thing was
not slithery that thing was floppity
what snakes are slithery
[Applause]
you think that slither is an absolute
when you said floppity you imagine if I
tell you something is floppity imagine
what you think it means that's what I'm
imagining a snake stretched out
completely straight going heel over tail
like flopping while going ten feet it's
not far off that's not far off you think
it's a bit but it's not what's left in
the rain and became bloated and then
came to life and forgot how to bend
yeah because sausage is know how to bend
even even inanimate objects know how to
be a snake better than that snake knows
how to be a snake I got I've been
searching for nests like crazy I've only
got nine eggs you need eggs
no I'm just getting eggs just because I
don't know what else to do because way
doesn't explained it to me animals I'm
trying
well I'm killing their children Oh
business me smash the heads of the
corpses it feels good it feels like this
he's like what you're supposed to do if
you can do that doesn't it seem like you
should do that yeah how to do it the
target so you mock my way guys I'm
cooking six bacon and eggs right now I
will be back and we'll make that four
jump and we'll get it good our base is
looking real secure guys our base is
looking juiciest dick the leathers over
here mark we put the words in this bill
yeah yeah the porridge also like if you
the more stuff you have in a building it
attracts zombies like produces either
light you're saying we should put it in
the garage or something probably should
forage in the garage we are sure that
the zombies won't
break our Forge some kind of thing
happened mark came out of nowhere
alright the drinks cooler is gonna be
the food storage all right Wade good
bacon and eggs right now I just want
everyone to know we have one minute
before it goes sideways well that's fun
because I need a minute to make this
voyage maybe we should just place the
forge in the morning maybe you should
shut your face I'm gonna go get some
iron to shove in the forge listen buddy
some of us like to play bold some of us
like to play like a pansy
sound good so I'm staying here with you
all right what do I need to make iron I
don't new forged iron ironing clay you
got it we've got um if we break down
like the trophies and stuff I've got
brass lead iron and [ __ ] to throw in
there I'm just gonna get it going with
I'm gonna get it going with iron first
for now well we can I think we can smelt
three different things at once yeah can
we not close these doors
we can't yeah five seconds four three
two one and done all right let's put
this here boom forges down putting
things in putting iron in its ominous
o'clock be careful my friends input okay
wait be careful my finals Oh Oh guys
guys come inside if you're in the garage
come inside right now it's so bad yes Oh
God I'm running